qualities question may I say how plowed
I was to host an event last night
marking the house Magazine's publication
of the list of 100 women in Westminster
it was an honor to celebrate so many
inspiring colleagues I wish them and
everyone a Happy International women's
day
right let's just start with questions to
the minister for women equalities we
start with naira Wilson question number
one Mr Speaker
uh thank you Mr Speaker gender pay Gap
reporting continues to motivate
employers to look at their pay data and
improve workplace gender equality and
huge progress is being made the gender
pay Gap has fallen by approximately a
quarter in the last decade but of course
there is more work to be done
can I thank the minister for her
response an 18 year old entering the
workforce today will not see gender pay
equality in her lifetime with the
national gender pay Gap at 14 and
growing will the minister Commit This
International women's day to ending the
motherhood penalty by fixing our broken
child care system and ensuring every
family can access affordable child care
uh well absolutely can I say it's this
conservative government that in 2017
introduced the world leading regulations
which has enabled us to be able to
record the gender pay Gap and and the
progress that we're making but we're
also committed to the child care aspect
which is uh difficult for many women
that's why we've announced additional
funding of 160 million pounds this year
180 million pounds next year 170 million
pounds the year after for local
authorities to increase the hourly rate
to pay for child care which is so
important to women
thank you Mr Speaker last year the
gender pay Gap was 12 higher than it was
in 2020 the year the minister for women
inequalities was first appointed to the
government equality's office
if not the minister for women under
qualities then can anyone on the
government front bench please apologize
to women for that increase this
International women's day
uh well thank you uh Mr Speaker for uh
uh I thank the shadow uh Secretary of
State for that question I mean it's
disappointed she can't welcome the
progress that has been made in fact
um it's not just in terms of the gender
pay Gap we're supporting paid
transparency which is equally important
in making sure women are paid the same
as men the stem returners pilot that
we're launching for 75 000 people to
return to the sem sector mainly women uh
careersly flexible working share
parental leave uh supporting The
Honorable for bath with her private
member's bill of harassment in the
workplace there's huge progress in
supporting women in work
at least odds thank you Mr Speaker no
apology then for that increase in the
gender pay Gap over recent years and no
real action it seems no other ons
figures show that the gender pay gap for
women in their 50s and 60s is nearly
four times higher than for those in
their 30s 185
000 women aged between 50 and 64 have
also left the workforce since 2020 at a
cost of 7 billion pounds to our economy
so will the minister back Labor's
proposal for larger companies to publish
menopause action plans to support women
to stay and work boost productivity and
grow our economy or will this action to
support working women just again be
dismissed as left-wing here
well I'm pleased that the labor party
are getting uh to the with the program
that they can actually Define what a
woman actually is for a start so we
won't take any lectures for them but
perhaps the labor party also need to get
their own house in order before
lecturing the rest of the country
because according to the telegraph in
January the labor party paid their black
workers nine percent less than their
white workers and absolutely need to get
their own house in order
SMB spokesperson customers will thank
you Mr Speaker as I highlighted to the
leader of the house last week the gender
peer gap between women and men currently
sits at nearly 15 and we know that women
are not are homogeneous groups so that
Gap will very further based on
intersecting characteristics including
ethnicity and disability status so I
wonder if the minister in line with the
theme for this year's International
women's day will Embrace Equity by
mandating gender pig out reporting and
action plans for all employers as well
as introducing ethnicity and disability
p-gap reporting requirements
well as I set out as this government in
2017 which set out the world leading
regulations requiring larger employers
to publish uh their average salaries but
that doesn't stop other employers from
doing the same if we we do would have to
pass new regulations to reduce that and
change the equality act but actually we
are seeing all employers wanting to
reduce the gender pay Gap and we're
leading the way in government with a
department for culture Media Sports and
DWP having eliminated that Gap in their
own Department robots to Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker I'm gonna have to
be quicker I'll never get in that
hundred Westminster
um
the law Commission commission commanded
against adding sex and gender to the
hate crime laws it found that the
addition of these characteristics might
make the prosecution of crimes which
disproportionately affect women and
girls actually more difficult the
government shares the law commission's
concern Parliament has repeatedly voted
against making misogyny a hate crime
last year and there are no plans to
change
awesome thank you Mr Speaker I am
recognize the arguments that have been
made most violence against women
originally in misogyny therefore making
misogynier hate crime would send such a
powerful signal to all offenders at all
their offenses would be taken with the
utmost seriousness and investigated
properly victims our vain cousins have
have argued that if only their reports
against this indecent exposure would
have been taken seriously Sarah everard
might still be alive today Mr Speaker
isn't a time that we make misogyny a
hate crime
I beg to disagree it may send a signal
but it's more of a virtual signal than a
real signal we have more police officers
than ever and we are determined to Stamp
Out violence against women and girls
thank you Mr Speaker Health disparities
exist across a wide variety of
conditions from cancer to mental health
and contribute to the unacceptable
variation in health outcomes therefore
the major conditions strategy which
we're launching will apply geographical
lens to end the disparities in health
outcomes across England
so James
what does she make of the interesting
comments by Chris witty around Health
inequalities in coastal areas like South
End and what are the governments are
proposing to do about those inequalities
well I think my right honorable friend
for that question he's absolutely right
there are disparities there's an eight a
year life difference between a woman
born in Blackpool and a woman born and
woking him and we want to end that
that's why our major condition strategy
is in parallel to the work NHS England's
doing on their core 20 plus five where
we're targeting the most deprived 20 of
populations in the country with the five
key health conditions that are making
those disparities apparent today it's in
Docker to use
Mr Speaker the average life expectancy
by women with a learning disability is
around 18 years shorter than women in
the general population so in this
International women's day what can a
minister say to women with learning
disabilities about the disparity in
their life expectancy well the horrible
gentleman makes a very good point and
that's exactly why mental health is part
of the major condition strategy because
people with mental health are learning
disabilities do suffer from poorer
physical health and that's why it's
absolutely crucial that we don't see if
you have if he listened to me he
returned I said learning disabilities
that is why it's crucial that we don't
see people with a learning disability in
isolation that we look after their
physical health as well as their
conditions that they suffer with the
minister Yasmine Qureshi yeah thank you
Miss
you missed her pregnant women who live
in the poorest areas of England are
twice as likely to die than those living
in the most affluent areas shockingly
black women are four times more likely
to die during childbirth this government
has had 13 years but has failed to
tackle maternal Health inequality what
action is the minister taking to address
these appalling disparities
well actually that's why we set up the
maternity disparities task force we're
working with the chief Midwife to drive
down those disparities and it's why
we're working with NHS England and why
maternity is one of those core 20 plus
five elements because we recognize this
huge disparities across the country
which we want to eliminate hello Morgan
before Please Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker the Departments are
taking uh talking to a range of
stakeholders to assess evidence and
options for a more targeted approach to
consumer protection from April 2024.
hello Morgan thank you Mr Speaker and
over 200 000 disabled households have
lost out on 150 pound one home discount
scheme due to a change in who the
government deems entitled to claim
including people in my constituency
disabled people often require additional
energy to run specialist equipment and
to keep their homes warmer so given that
there's no appeals process will the
minister agree to
review this problem in the system and
work with colleagues to address it next
year
great thank you Mr Speaker this
government has been committed to
supporting disabled people and a whole
range of people around the cost of
living crisis but of course as I have
mentioned we will be meeting and
discussing this
is Ben Bradshaw
question five sir
the government takes all forms of hate
crime seriously we accept expect the
police to fully investigate all of these
sorts of hateful attacks and make sure
the cowards who commit them fill the
full force of the law the government is
committed to reducing all crime
including hate crime which is why we are
recruiting 20 000 additional police
officers that Bradshaw she will know Mr
Speaker that trans people are already
the group most likely to be the victims
of violent crime and there was a massive
56 increase in hate crime against trans
people in the last year against what I
conceive to be a background of
semi-official transphobia in England
like the moral Panic that led to section
28 in the 1980s so what is her view of
the comments of her party's Deputy
chairman who called on the conservative
party to campaign and I quote on a mix
of culture wars and trans debates
with a greater respect I don't accept
the way the narrative has been put with
the deputy chairman of conservative
party we have to look at all of these
issues but what I want to say is I
welcome the increase in reporting of
just the sort of offenses that The
Honorable member says because it's only
when people come forward that we can do
something about it and I think the
increase in numbers to 56 from 43
previously is a good thing because it
means people are having more confidence
than the police there is more to do but
I certainly don't accept that this
government is as against assisting this
era as is said we're putting huge
amounts of education and effort into
this and we will we will reap the
benefits over it in the years to come
Angela
thank you Mr Speaker question six
thank you Mr Speaker the government has
taken steps to modernize the application
process for obtaining a gender
recognition certificate and to make an
application more affordable applicants
for a GRC are now required to pay five
pound in the newly developed digital
application process for grcs launched on
the 29th of June last year
does the minister agree it's important
to have a consistent approach for the
recognize the recognition of overseas
countries GRC schemes and that because
of the complex interaction with the
equalities act its rights to recognize
only those countries that have
equivalent approaches
Minister Mr Speaker consistent approach
to grc's is fundamental to the effective
functioning of legislation in this area
the GP wide equality Act was carefully
drafted in light of and reflecting the
specific limits of the uk-wide gender
recognition act it is important for the
effective functioning of the equality
act that recognition of international
grcs is in line with the basic
principles of the gra Jim Shannon you Mr
Speaker I think the the minister for his
response there are many people in
Northern Ireland in the United Kingdom
as a whole who have concerns over gender
recognition certificates has the
minister had any opportunity to talk to
some of those organizations to get their
opinions so when we draw up a policy
that it's one that's recognized by
everyone
so Mr Speaker I recognize that this is
an area of of considerable concern for
some but I think it is important that
the debate is one that is calm and
measured and absolutely respects the
individuals involved I have many
meetings with people from around the
country on these specific issues and we
take careful consideration of all the
points that are made making sure that
everybody feels confident that the law
is in the right place
speaker question seven yeah
uh thank you Mr Speaker the department
for business and trade is Keen to
support entrepreneurs from all
communities evidenced by a
disproportionately high proportion of
startup loans accessed by ethnic
minority-led businesses the government
supported action was aimed at improving
opportunities for ethnic minority
entrepreneurs set out the inclusive
Britain report and we'll be reporting
back to Parliament shortly
decision-making leadership commitment
confidence resilience teamwork and
self-esteem are all skills and
attributes essential to
entrepreneurialism and that is also the
case uh that these can be fostered by
high quality physical education in
schools which is why today's
announcement is 600 million pounds over
two years to support Primary School PE
in sport is so welcome but it's also the
case Mr Speaker that Sports England
reported in December that children young
people of black Asian and other
ethnicities are least likely to be
active so will my honorable friend use
his good offices to upgrade from
government aspirations government policy
the association for physical education
nation's recommendation to make p a core
subject in schools to help tackle this
unacceptable disparity
here here Mr Speaker as someone who
benefited from playing football rugby
and Cricket at my state school I am
delighted at today's announcement as the
year refers to my original friend the
Secretary of State for education is
today announced a package of activity to
boost equal opportunities in school
sport both inside and outside the
classroom
hey Mr speaker
Mr Speaker may I take question 8 and 14
together tackling violence against women
and girls is a government priority and
something I regularly discuss with my
colleagues we have added Finance against
women and girls to the Strategic
policing requirement meaning it is set
out as a national threat for police's
forces to respond to alongside issues
such as terrorism we have launched a 36
million pound fund for interventions for
domestic abuse perpetrators to improve
the safety and feeling of safety of
victims their children and to risk and
to reduce the risk pose by birth Traders
thank you Mr Speaker it is a sad fact
that walking home at night is for too
many women and girls a time when they
feel exposed to danger and Mr Speaker
this is unacceptable but sadly for soon
when they get home home is not a place
of Refuge it is a place of danger during
the periods of the national lockdown in
the pandemic this became a reality for
more women and girls with the police and
domestic abuse Support Services
reporting an increase in cases of
victims experience abuse in their own
homes so will my right honorable friend
advise me what what progress has been
made in support in the front line
services
I'm pleased to be able to say that North
family PCC has received 3.7 million
across a safer streets fan today the 750
000 through the current round four of a
range of interventions on transport and
therapy and what I also would like to
say is that we have training for NHS to
make sure we have an old systems process
to improving this better training for
those that work in healthcare in
education a whole system approach this
government is committed to assisting
so rapidly
I see a father of three young women like
any parent I worry about their safety
Society seems to become harder and
old-fashioned values of respect towards
women seem to be Vanishing in many parts
of our society even in the police so
what practical efforts can the
government make to make young women feel
safe in the streets particularly in
areas of our great cities yeah yeah well
I know that the Prime Minister has
daughters and shares your concerns what
I can say is that Lincolnshire police
and crime commissioner has received 1.3
million across the safest streets round
so far there's almost 400 000 in the
current round four for extra CCTV and
police training to respond to ball this
is part of a wider picture and we are
advancing I'm very proud of what the
government's doing
Mr Speaker an Afghan woman is smuggled
into the UK on a small boat because she
can't access the resettlement scheme
once here she is trafficked into
prostitution and abused by a grooming
gang under the government's new bill
she'd be unable to access modern slavery
support and she'd be returned to an
unsafe country does the minister agree
we must make sure that all vulnerable
women are safe from these kind of
questions
there is a lot of work going on with
engaging with stakeholder groups to see
what we can do to make sure that
everyone is safe I've spoken to several
groups about this issue and it's being
considered let nobody be mistaken this
government is extremely strong and
making sure that vulnerable women
wherever they come from are safe man
production thank you Mr Speaker sadly
cat calling and other gender-based
microaggressions are still commonplace
in schools
just a sexual abuse support service who
works closely with schools across my
constituency tell me there's still a
lack of awareness education and
prevention regarding these issues will
the minister tell me what's been done to
Resource schools to raise awareness and
help young people challenge behaviors
which lead to abuse
there's a wide range of work that's
going on within schools with their
training to make sure that young people
understand more clearly what is and what
is not accessible and acceptable in
relation to more National interventions
we have issues such as they ask for Ali
scheming pharmacies and also we have the
enough social media campaign and that's
really cut through the responses we've
had have been unprecedented to that
campaign so this government is committed
and making good progress to assist young
people to understanding what is and what
is not acceptable
it's a speaker can I wish everyone a
happy International women's day where we
celebrate 51 of the population I'm proud
of this government's record in
supporting whether women whether it's
young girls playing more sport in school
or the first ever Women's Health
strategy which this year will roll out
the prepayments certificate for HRT
pregnancy loss certificates this summer
and the leveling up of IVF access I'm
proud Mr Speaker to announce today 25
billion pounds to roll out Women's
Health hubs across England the One-Stop
shop for All Women's Health needs which
will drastically improve women's
experience of Healthcare in England
Chris Stevens thank you Mr Speaker the
minister will be aware of our legal
agreement under their qualities act
between McDonald's and their qualities
and Human Rights Commission people
cannot walk in front of a member when
he's asking his question Mr Stevens Mr
Speaker the minister will be aware of a
legal agreement under the qualities act
between McDonald's and their qualities
and Human Rights Commission over the
handling of complaints of sexual
harassment does the minister believe
that solely an issue of a toxic culture
and McDonald's I will show you look at
whether women working on zero or
contracts across the economy at an
increased risk of experiencing sexual
harassment because of depending on male
managers for future shifts well we take
Section harassment in the workplace very
seriously
oh to be shattered down by the entrance
of a man and we take this stuff and this
stuff
nobody will show to you though now I'm
just every time when the plan just comes
they'll happen again don't worry come on
I'll try again then Mr Speaker uh once
again the government is very uh Keen to
tackle sexual harassment in the
workplace that's why we're supporting
them remember as far uh her private
members bill because it is such a
serious issue
Simon Jeff thank you Mr Speaker I'm
proud to be backing a campaign to
improve uh services for menopause
sufferers in the county of Devon in
society and at work stigma remains a
barrier for many people to get the
support they require can my honorable
friend outline what steps the government
is taking to prevent menopause
discrimination in the workplace
Mr Speaker we're working with employers
and employees on this crucial matter to
make sure there is no Stigma in the
workplace for those experienced the
impact of menopause and to this end I
was delighted to announce on Monday the
appointment of Helen Tomlinson as the
DWP menopause employment Champion she'll
have a key role driving awareness
promoting the benefits to both business
and the economy of a fully inclusive
workplace click thank you Mr Speaker
disabled people are more than twice as
likely to have experience domestic abuse
and sexual violence as non-disabled
people the national disabled strategy
set out the roadmap to improve the
protection and supports available to
disabled people in their homes but was
last year found to be unlawful by the
high court for not having giving the
disabled community and adequate
opportunity to shape the strategy can
the minister confirm that cycling the
stage of violence against disabled
people will be essential priority of the
new disability action plan and will she
guarantee that the new action power will
be shaped by desert
violence against disabled people in the
home or anywhere is just as important as
Vine Escape anybody else and we are
given unprecedented monies towards
stopping this sort of violence it's all
about education the police Chiefs
Council and the policing College of
policing are working hard on this and we
are making progress the James Judd Rich
Mr Speaker a young man often struggle
with their mental health particularly
Suicidal Thoughts that can hits like a
heart attack what more can the
government do indeed what more can each
individual member of this house do to
help those young men
I was setting out the prevention of
suicide strategies where we're looking
at high risk groups like men but can I
also point out what the home office is
doing and setting up helplines for men
there's two hundred thousand pounds
going into those helplines and so far
they've supported ten thousand men
who've needed support
Stephen Morgan thank you Mr Speaker new
businesses are almost three times as
likely to be started by men as by women
does the minister agree with Labor's
plan to work with the British Business
Bank to support female Founders achieve
their ambitions
[Applause]
[Music]
um well the labor party are once again
late to the party because the
conservative government already
delivering on this who set up the high
growth task force getting more women
into setting up their businesses but
high growth businesses and to end the
disparity and Venture Capital where for
every pound that's given 89 Perth
currently goes to men's businesses and
only a penny to women